Buenas noches normalmente la pérdida
desperdicio de alimentos se asocian a
fallas en la planeación de la producción
a veces la demanda es inferior a la
oferta o ese también a la falta
infraestructura y a la inversión en
transporte o sea estándares estéticos
muchas veces lo que se pide lo que se
reconoce en el mercado no responde a
como lucen muchos de los alimentos y
también a muchas decisiones de consumo
familia una de las primeras cosas que
uno piensa por supuesto al encontrarse
con esta información Cuántas personas
podrían ser alimentadas no con este
volumen de comida desperdiciada maneja
una cifra usted o desde la organización
Pues mira normalmente el análisis que
hacemos Es que a 20-50 se va a duplicar
la población global y si logramos
contener y reducir la pérdida y
desperdicio de alimentos y logramos
cambiar ciertos hábitos de consumo
podríamos tener suficientes alimentos
para cubrir la de esa población que se
duplica el informe prevé un incremento
no como lo decíamos de los desperdicios
para la próxima década porque esta
tendencia
digamos que los problemas estructurales
no se han solucionado normalmente
tenemos pues una crisis económica
tenemos una crisis climática hay una
falta de políticas sólidas que logren Eh
pues generar las condiciones necesarias
para los cambios también hay una falta
de cambios de patrones de consumo
entonces pues esto nos está llevando a
que el problema no ha sido resuelto pero
seguimos
apostándole a una mayor producción de
alimentos basado en un crecimiento
poblacional en una mayor demanda para ir
finalizando Qué medidas se recomienda
para contrarrestar y reducir esta
tendencia al desperdicio de los
alimentos
pues definitivamente es súper importante
que hayan políticas públicas que nos
lleven a contener este problema pero
también se pueden empezar por procesos
de medir es importantísimo medir para
poder tomar acciones para reducir es
importante también cambiar esos
estándares de de compra y estándares
estéticos
es obviamente atender varios de los
puntos de la agenda climática que es muy
importante y como consumidores podemos
también hacer muchas cosas podemos pues
seguir aumentando la conciencia en el
proceso de toma de decisiones y a la
hora de dejar algo en el plato o cuando
estamos comprando en exceso podemos
tomar medida para reducir al desperdicio
de alimentos
Muchísimas gracias por este análisis